dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here the
last few years have been an amazing ride
when it comes to research works for
creating facial reenactments for real
characters beyond just transferring our
gestures to a video footage of an
existing talking head controlling their
gestures like video game characters and
full body movement transfer are also a
possibility with wavenet and its many
variants we can also learn someone's way
of speaking write a piece of text and
make an audio waveform where we can
impersonate them using their own voice
so what else is there to do in this
domain are we done no no not at all hold
onto your papers because with this
amazing new technique what we can do is
look at the transcript of a talking head
video remove parts of it or add to it
just as we would edit any piece of text
and this technique produces both the
audio and the matching video of this
person uttering these words check this
out
okay the market closed today with
Apple's stock price at 180 2.25 dollars
per share it works by looking through
the video collecting small sounds that
can be used to piece together this new
word that we've added to the transcript
the authors demonstrate this by adding
the word Fox to the transcript this can
be pieced together by the V which
appears in the word Viper and taking aux
as a part of another word found in the
footage as a result one can make the
character say fox without ever hearing
her uttering this word before then we
can look for not only the audio
occurrences for these sounds but the
video footage of how they are being said
and in the paper the technique is
proposed to blend these video assets
together finally we can provide all this
information to a neuro renderer that
synthesizes a smooth video of this
talking head this is a beautiful
architecture with lots of contributions
so make sure to have a look at the paper
in the description for more details and
of course as it is not easy to measure
the quality of these results in a
mathematical manner the user study was
made when they asked some fellow humans
which is the real footage and which one
was edited you will see the footage
edited by this algorithm on the right
the dingo ate my baby the dingo ate my
baby
and hmm it's not easy to tell which one
is which and it also shows in the
numbers which are not perfect but they
clearly show that the fake video is very
often confused with the real one did you
find any artifacts that give the trick
away perhaps the sentence was said a
touch faster than expected found
anything else let me know in the
comments below the paper also contains
tons of comparisons against previous
works so in the last few years the trend
seems clear the bar is getting lower it
is getting easier and easier to produce
these kinds of videos and it is getting
harder and harder to catch them with our
naked eyes and now we can edit the
transcript of what is being said which
is super convenient I would like to note
that a is also exists that can detect
these edited videos with a high
confidence I put up the ethical
considerations of the author's here it
is definitely worthy of your attention
as it discusses how they think about
these techniques the motivation for this
work was mainly to enhance digital
storytelling by removing filler words
potentially flubbed phrases or retiming
sentences in talking head videos there
is so much more to it
so make sure to pause the video and read
their full statement thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time